This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。嘿，你们好吗？欢迎收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Kear Games。这个节目旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都感觉不太安全、无法进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个深谙此道的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，就必须去使用它，听听如何
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA电台应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听hard way节目。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探出动，才揭露出了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《情网难逃》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《情网难逃》播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last
这就是当旁边有自动扶梯时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、健康体魄以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请收听《2%》。也就是TWA%，在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们约会的竟然是同一个高产的骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我要成为他的最后
target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he does. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners. It is so great to have you here back for another episode, a super, super exciting episode because we are being joined by an incredible guest who I will let introduce herself in
一个目标。他绝对不能就这么逃脱。他会为自己的所作所为付出代价。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《相信我，宝贝，听闺蜜的》。欢迎回到《二十岁心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活改变和过渡，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎新老听众回到播客。非常高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，这是一期超级超级精彩的节目，因为我们迎来了一位不可思议的嘉宾，我将让她自己来介绍
just a second. But today we're going to talk about dating in your 20s. It's a bit of a series that we've been doing on the podcast recently. but today I really want to dive into knowing your worth, dealing with rejection and moving on. And I thought, who better to come on and share their wisdom than Liz from the Date Yourself Instead podcast. Hello, how are you? You're making me smile so much. I love your intro.
只需一秒钟。但今天我们要聊的是二十多岁的约会。这是我们最近在播客中一直在做的一个系列节目。但今天我真的很想深入探讨了解自己的价值、应对拒绝以及向前迈进。我想，还有谁比来自《约会你自己》播客的莉兹更适合来分享他们的智慧呢？你好，最近怎么样？你让我笑得好开心。我太喜欢你的开场白了。
You have such a soothing, calming voice. I feel like you have like an amazing podcast voice. And thank you so much for having me on the podcast. I am such a fan of yours. I found you while I was scrolling through Spotify one day and I was looking for a new podcast that kind of had the same feel of mine, like self-help, self-love, self-care. And I found your podcast and I started listening to this.
你的声音太舒缓、太让人平静了。我觉得你的播客声音简直太棒了。非常感谢邀请我来上播客。我是你的超级粉丝。有一天我刷Spotify时发现了你，当时我在找一个新的播客，它那种自我帮助、自我爱、自我关怀的氛围和我有点像。然后我发现了你的播客，并开始听这个。
And I was like, I would get along with this girl. She seems amazing. Oh, my goodness. And I feel like we do. Before we even hit record, where just like having a bit of a bit of a yarn, like having a bit of a chit-chat about everything and anything. So it was the intersection of worlds that needed to happen. Yes, I'm so excited.
当时我就想，我会和这个女孩很合得来。她看起来太棒了。哦，天哪。我觉得我们的确很合得来。甚至在按下录音键之前，我们就只是像在闲聊一样，天南海北地聊着一切。所以这是两种世界的交汇，是命中注定的。是的，我太兴奋了。
I messaged you. I messaged Emma on Instagram and I was like, I don't know if she's going to answer because I feel like her podcast is better than mine. Oh, I don't know about that. There's no competition. I was like, no, I'm kidding. But honestly, like I really love your content. and like the message you spread to everyone and I yeah I just I love everything that you're doing so I am honored to be on your podcast today.
我给你发了私信。我给艾玛发了Instagram私信，当时我想，不知道她会不会回我，因为我觉得她的播客比我的好。哦，别这么说。根本没有竞争。我是说，不，开玩笑的。但老实说，我真的很喜欢你的内容。以及你传达给每个人的信息，我，是的，我太喜欢你所做的一切了，所以今天能荣幸地来到你的播客做客。
Oh and you know what the feeling is so mutual. I feel like we're just having a little bit of a hype circle here where we're just like we love each other. But it's true like if you haven't, well for people who haven't listened to your show, I feel like a lot of people who listen to the psychology of your 20s would get a lot out of date yourself instead. Do you want to kind of talk about what kind of episodes you do, what you guys talk about over on your show? Yeah, for sure. So I started the podcast.
哦，你知道吗，这种感觉是相互的。我觉得我们现在就像是在互相吹捧，互相表达喜爱。但这是真的，如果你还没听过，嗯，对于那些还没听过你的节目的人来说，我觉得很多听《二十岁心理学》的人会从《约会你自己》中收获很多。你想不想聊聊你们节目平时都做什么类型的节目，你们都聊些什么话题？好的，没问题。所以我是从什么时候开始这个播客的。
It's called Date Yourself Instead. And I started it right after a really bad breakup that I went through last year. And it took so much out of me. Like I felt like my life had completely fallen apart. And I was so dependent on this relationship to get me through my day. I was very dependent on it to make me feel good about myself. And I realized when we had broken up that I didn't know who I was. And I felt really lost and confused.
它叫《约会你自己》。我是去年经历了一次非常糟糕的分手后立刻开始做的。那次经历抽干了我的精力。我觉得我的生活彻底崩溃了。我太依赖这段关系来度过每一天了。我非常依赖它来让我对自己感觉良好。分手后我意识到，我根本不知道自己是谁。我感到非常迷茫和困惑。
So I eventually, after I went through the healing process, of course, I came up with this idea called Date Yourself Instead. And I started really working on myself and building myself back up again. And I decided that I wanted to also spread this message to other people that were going through similar things that I was going through. And what better way to do that than a podcast? So it became, I started one episode in the midst of my breakup and I realized that it was what I wanted to do.
所以，在我经历了疗愈过程之后，我最终想出了“约会你自己”这个概念。我开始真正努力提升自己，重新建立自我。我决定把这个信息也传达给那些和我经历相似的人。还有什么比播客更好的方式呢？所以它就成了这样，我在分手期间录制了第一集，我意识到这就是我想做的事。
Like I just wanted to help other women and men and anyone else that's going through a breakup. So a lot of my contents dedicated to healing, becoming the best version of yourself, and dating yourself. I love it. I feel like we need more content like that. What was the, do you remember what the first episode was on? I feel like there must have been, I also started my show after a breakup. I feel like that's like, I don't know, like it really pushes you.
就像我只想帮助其他经历分手的女性、男性以及任何人。所以我的很多内容都致力于疗愈、成为最好的自己以及与自己约会。我太喜欢了。我觉得我们需要更多这样内容的节目。当时是怎样的，你还记得第一集是关于什么的吗？我觉得一定有，我也是在分手后开始做节目的。我觉得那真的，我不知道，它真的会推你一把。
Like it triggers you to take action. It does actually. Like I always say that a breakup is actually kind of sacred because normally you identify and find these entirely new opportunities that you've been entirely and completely blind to up until that point. But it's like in a breakup, right? There's like this desperation to reclaim parts of your identity that you feel have been like co-opted by that other person.
就像它触发你采取行动一样。确实如此。我总是说，其实分手某种程度上是神圣的，因为通常你会发现并找到这些全新的机会，在此之前你对它们是完全盲目的。但就像在分手时，对吧？你会有一种迫切渴望，想要找回那些你觉得被另一个人同化的自我身份部分。
And starting a podcast is a great way to do that because your voice is kind of the only one that matters. But you also get to really step into yourself and really, I don't know if you find this, but you really have to contemplate the things that you're talking about and come to the table with some form of like mature thinking about it. So it kind of allows you to like undertake your grieving process and your healing process in a place of like almost accountability. I don't know. Is that what you kind of found?
而开始做播客是实现这一目标的好方法，因为你的声音某种程度上是唯一重要的声音。但你也可以真正走进自我，真的，我不知道你是不是也这么觉得，你必须深入思考你正在谈论的事情，并带着某种成熟的思考来到这里。所以它某种程度上允许你在一个几乎是自我负责任的地方进行你的悲伤和疗愈过程。我不知道。你是这么觉得的吗？
I 100% agree with that. While I was going through all these emotions and I was at my worst, like I was literally at the lowest point of my life. I realized that if I wanted to help other people and create this content, I needed to be held accountable and actually follow what I was saying. So a lot of the time I would be recording episodes and I'd be going through certain things. And I felt like in a way it was like therapy for me because I was going through similar things that my audience is going through and I was able to speak on it, but it was also really healing. And yeah, I mean, I think when you're forced to kind of speak about it and make content about it, it kind of helps you in the healing process.
我百分之百赞同这一点。当我经历所有这些情绪，处于人生最低谷的时候，我真的处于人生的最低点。我意识到，如果我想帮助别人并创作这些内容，我就需要对自己负责，并且真正践行我所说的话。所以很多时候我会在录制节目时正经历着某些事情。我觉得某种程度上这就像是我的治疗，因为我正在经历听众们正在经历的类似事情，我能够谈论它，但这同时也是一种疗愈。是的，我的意思是，当你被迫谈论它并围绕它创作内容时，它确实会在疗愈过程中对你有所帮助。
Yeah, I can only imagine. I can only imagine, but I've also experienced that. And I do think it's one of such a beautiful, beautiful way to connect with others. Was there any like, was there like a turning point episode that you did where you were like, oh, I'm actually coming through this? Like, I can see that the person that I was when I first started this show in a point of probably grief and just like total confusion has now evolved. Yeah, I definitely think.
是的，我完全可以想象。我完全可以想象，但我也经历过。而且我确实认为这是一种与他人建立联系的非常美丽、非常美妙的方式。有没有哪个转折点的节目，让你当时觉得，哦，我真的走出来了？就像我能看出，当刚开始做这个节目时，我还处于悲伤和彻底困惑的状态，而现在那个我，已经蜕变了。是的，我绝对觉得。
After starting the podcast, I started talking about more than just breakups, just stepping into your power and knowing your worth, which obviously we're going to talk about today, which is super exciting. Just knowing your value and self-love is not just about, you know, working out and I guess like doing a self-care day. It's not really about those surface level things, I guess. I don't know the right word to call it. I don't know if it's surface level. or it's more like physical actions. Like those things help and they supplement self-love. But true self-love is really like inner work.
在开始做播客之后，我开始谈论不仅仅是分手的话题，而是真正掌控自己的力量并了解自己的价值，显然我们今天要谈论这个，这太让人兴奋了。仅仅知道你的价值和自我爱不仅仅是关于，你知道的，健身，或者说进行一次自我关怀日。它其实并不关乎那些表面的东西，我猜。我不知道该用什么词来称呼它。我不知道这算不算表面，或者它更像是身体上的行动。这些事情会有所帮助，它们是对自我爱的补充。但真正的自我爱其实是内在的工作。
You know, it's actually looking within yourself when you're alone and you're not distracted by any external things. And I think the how to take your power back after a breakup episode really kind of open my eyes to a lot of different things about it's not just, you know, going for a run and clearing your head and talking to a friend. It's really looking within yourself. and understanding your value as a human being and understanding that if it didn't work out with someone that doesn't take away from who you are and that doesn't make you any less of a person.
你知道的，当你独自一人，没有被任何外部事物分散注意力时，真正审视自己的内心。我觉得“分手后如何夺回自己的力量”那一集确实让我对很多事情有了新的认识，它不只是去跑步、清醒一下头脑和跟朋友聊天。而是真正审视内心。
And for the longest time, I would beat myself up over a relationship not working. And I would beat myself up over mistakes that I made in relationships. And yeah, that episode I think really covers a lot of that. There's a few, I'm sure. Yeah, I'll have to listen to that. I have to say I haven't been through a breakup any time recently, although I do still think it would apply to my general dating history. So maybe I'll definitely go back and listen to that.
理解自己作为人的价值，并且明白如果和某个人没有走到最后，这并不代表你的价值减少了，也不会让你变成一个逊色的人。而且在很长一段时间里，我会因为一段关系没有成功而自我苛责。我会为自己在恋爱中犯下的错误而自我苛责。是的，我想那一集确实涵盖了很多这方面的内容。肯定还有一些其他的。是的，我一定要去听听那一集。我得说我最近没经历过分手，虽然我依然觉得这适用于我的整体约会历史。所以也许我绝对会回去听听那一集。
But I feel like you just mentioned it. It's a great segue. Like one of the things I really wanted to kind of discuss today was self-worth and kind of your 20s, self-worth and dating, self-worth and relationships. And I feel like it is such an intricate interaction. between how we feel about ourselves, which as you and I both know, is not something that is surface level
但我觉得你刚才提到了。这是一个很好的过渡。就像我今天真正想讨论的事情之一是自我价值，以及你二十多岁时的自我价值与约会、自我价值与恋爱关系。我觉得它们之间存在着如此错综复杂的互动。
by any means. It takes a lot of hard work. It takes a lot of honesty. It sometimes takes a lot of pain. But our self-worth really does have this, like, kind of bleed on impact on who we choose to date, how we approach dating, how we approach rejection,
在我们对自己的感觉之间，正如你我都知道的那样，这绝不是浮于表面的一件事。这需要付出很多努力。需要很多诚实。有时还需要很多痛苦。但我们的自我价值确实对我们选择和谁约会、我们如何对待约会、我们如何对待被拒绝，有着这种类似“溢出”的影响。
how we approach even breakups as well. So I kind of was like, I want to hear you. your perspective on this, both anecdotal and from, I'm sure, like, people who have messaged you and research that you've done in the past. Yeah, for sure. I think self-worth and self-love, it needs to be the focus of your life in order to attract healthier relationships. And we're not taught this when we're younger. I mean, at least I wasn't taught this. Some people have really healthy upbringing. So I'm not going to speak on it, like everyone's experience. But for my
我们甚至如何对待分手。所以我想听听你的看法，既有轶事方面的，也有来自于，我确信，那些给你发私信的人以及你过去做过的研究。是的，当然。我认为自我价值和自我爱需要成为你生活的重点，以便吸引更健康的感情。我们在年轻时并没有被教导这一点。我的意思是，至少我没有被教导过。有些人有非常健康的成长环境。所以我不会代表所有人的经历发言。但就我个人而言
experience and a lot of other people that I'm sure can relate to this my childhood was not emotionally fulfilling in the way I think that I needed and it wasn't you know I'm not blaming my parents I'm not blaming other people because everyone's just doing their best and my parents love me but I just maybe I didn't really get the love and validation I needed and it kind of bled into the rest of my relationships as I started getting older and it affected my level of self-worth and self-love. So I would attract all these men into my life that didn't value me. And I really believe that you mirror your partners.
经历以及很多能对此感同身受的人，我的童年并没有在我觉得需要的方式上给予我情感上的满足，而且这不是，你知道的，我没有责怪我的父母，我也没有责怪其他人，因为每个人都在尽力而为，我的父母爱我，但我可能真的没有得到我需要的爱和肯定，这在我长大的过程中蔓延到了我其余的亲密关系中，并影响了我的自我价值感和自爱感。所以我会在生活中吸引所有这些不珍惜我的男人。我真的相信你会吸引和你相似的伴侣。
I believe that you attract who you are in a way and at what phase of life you're in. So when I didn't love myself, I would attract people who really didn't see my worth at all. And I think that's a key thing to note when you're exploring this conversation. concept of self-love and self-worth is that you kind of attract who you are. So in order to attract someone who's right for you and healthy for you, it's important to channel all your energy inwards and really work on yourself before you jump into a relationship as I've learned the hard way. Oh, I agree as well. I feel like it is there are two kind of schools of thought on that. Like you need to be healed before you can love or you can be healed by love. I definitely
我相信你会吸引到和你相似的人，以及处于你人生哪个阶段的人。所以当我并不爱自己的时候，我会吸引那些根本看不到我的价值的人。我认为这是在探讨自爱和自我价值这个概念时需要注意的关键一点，那就是你往往会吸引到和你相似的人。所以为了吸引到那个对你合适、对你健康的人，重要的是把所有的能量都向内收，在投入一段感情之前真正努力提升自己，正如我通过艰难方式学到的那样。哦，我也赞同。我觉得在这个问题上有两种观点。就像你需要在爱之前被疗愈，或者你可以通过爱来被疗愈。我绝对
fall more into like the first camp of like you need to heal before you can love and I think I had a similar experience where growing up like I was always kind of the ugly kid or like the fat kid or the strange child this is like oh but it's true and I fucking love that little version of me like she was just having the best time ever but at time she also wasn't because it was like I wasn't very accepted. I always felt like I had to change something about myself in order to fit in or I never really felt that my worth was something that other people could see. And I had to make that really obvious to them by being super generous or like changing something about myself or yeah, whatever kind of behavior it was. And I think it's not always acknowledged that your early
更倾向于第一种阵营，也就是你需要先疗愈才能去爱，而且我认为我有过类似的经历，那就是成长过程中，我总是那种丑小孩、胖小孩或者奇怪的孩子，这就像，哦，但这是真的，我他妈太爱那个小小的自己了，她当时过得开心极了，但同时她也没有，因为就像我并不是很被接纳。我总是觉得我必须改变自己的某些方面才能融入进去，或者我从来不觉得自己的价值是别人能看到的。我必须通过表现得超级慷慨或者改变自己的某些方面，或者，无论是什么样的行为，来让他们非常明显地看到这一点。而且我认为人们并不总是承认，你早期的经历对你影响深远
childhood experiences, like you said, are so fundamental and almost determined so much of how we see ourselves moving forward. And I think there was like this point in like my like late teens, like 19 or 20 years old where I was just like, oh my God, I have spent my entire life feeling like I do not deserve love. I do not deserve compassion. I do not. I do not deserve deep, meaningful relationships and friendship. And I kind of like surveyed the landscape of fallen partners and previous boyfriends and was like, wow, all of these people treated me exactly how I was asking to be treated. Because when you really don't see yourself as being worth much, the bar is so low and you accept that treatment because you believe that you deserve it.
正如你所说，童年经历是如此基础，几乎决定了我们以后如何看待自己。我想在我快要成年的晚期，比如19或20岁的时候，我突然觉得，天哪，我一辈子都觉得自己不配得到爱。我不配得到同情。我真的不配。我不配拥有深厚、有意义的恋爱关系和友谊。我环顾了一下周围那些失败的伴侣和前男友，心想，哇，所有这些人对待我的方式，正是我要求他们那样对待我的方式。因为当你真的觉得自己的价值不高时，标准就会变得很低，你会接受那种对待，因为你相信自己配得上。
Like, what's that quote from perks of being a wallflower? I know it's such a common one, but like you, we accept the love we think we deserve. Yeah, I've heard that before. That's a good one. Yeah, it's like kind of cliche, but it's also, I think as you get older, you realize that it's quite true, would you say? I definitely agree with that. And also back to what you had said earlier, that stuck out to me about the two different points of you where you know you can be healed by love or you need to heal before you dive into a relationship
就像《壁花少年》里的那句台词是什么来着？我知道这很常见，但我们接受我们自认为配得上的爱。是的，我以前听过。这句话真好。是的，这听起来有点老套，但随着年龄的增长，你也会发现它是相当真实的，你觉得呢？我绝对同意这一点。还有回到你刚才说的那个触动我的观点，关于你对自己的两种看法：一种是你可以通过爱来治愈，另一种是你需要在陷入一段感情之前先治愈自己。
whatever it is um i think it's obviously a case-by-case situation but i did have an experience once where i came out of an abusive relationship with someone that called me all sorts of things and it was not healthy at all whatsoever and two days later i met this guy that actually took me into his world and told me how beautiful I was and he helped me on my healing journey. So I will say that there's two sides to it. I don't think you need to be completely healed 100% because we all go through shit. We're human beings. We're never going to have this. Nothing is ever perfect. So you're never going to be fully healed 100% of the time. And as you get older, you realize that too is like, you're always going to have highs and lows and that's just a part of life. So,
不管怎样，嗯，我认为这显然要视具体情况而定，但我确实有过一次经历，当时我刚结束一段虐待性的关系，对方叫我各种难听的绰号，而且完全不健康。两天后，我遇到了这个家伙，他实际上把我带入了她的世界，告诉我我是多么美丽，他陪伴我走过了疗愈之旅。所以我想说的是，这有两面性。我不认为你需要100%完全治愈，因为我们都会经历操蛋的事情。我们是人。我们永远不会拥有完美的时刻。没有什么事是完美的。所以你永远不可能100%完全治愈。随着年龄的增长，你也会意识到这一点，那就是你总是会经历高潮和低谷，这只是生活的一部分。所以，
I wouldn't say you need to be fully healed, but I think you do need to develop a sense of self-worth and know your value. And I think those are two kind of separate things. Yeah, I would actually agree. And I think it also like comes to the point of acknowledging your self-worth is kind of the first step on a long journey. And perhaps one of the most crucial, especially if you're someone who finds themselves in very similar relationships, time after time. it might be worth examining what the root cause of that is. Because obviously you've learnt the lesson, you don't need to go through another shitty relationship.
我不会说你需要完全治愈，但我认为你确实需要培养一种自我价值感，并知道自己的价值。我认为这是两种不同的东西。是的，我其实很赞同。而且我认为这也关系到承认你的自我价值，这是一段漫长旅程的第一步。也许是最关键的一步之一，尤其是如果你发现自己一次又一次陷入非常相似的感情中。这或许值得去探讨一下其根本原因是什么。因为很显然你已经吸取了教训，你不需要再经历另一段糟糕的感情了。
You don't need to go through another awful experience. So examining what it might be, you know, obviously there are some people out there who are just really awful narcissistic people who are never going to change. It's not your fault that they treated you like that. but it is worth examining like, oh, why is it that I tolerate this behavior or why is it that I find this attractive or why do I keep ending up in these situations where I know that I don't feel valued and I know that these people do not deserve me? Yeah, for sure.
你不需要再经历另一段糟糕的经历。所以去探讨那可能是什么，当然，有些人真的很糟糕，是永远不会改变的自恋狂。他们那样对你不是你的错。但确实值得探讨一下，比如，为什么我能容忍这种行为，或者为什么我发现这很有吸引力，或者为什么我总是陷入这些让我觉得没有价值、且知道这些人根本配不上我的情境中？是的，确实如此。
I think we often tend to attract the same type of people over and over again if we haven't learned the lesson and we haven't looked within ourselves. And it's back to the whole concept of really learning about solving. love. It's not about going and having a spa day all the time, even though those things are nice to make you feel good in the moment, long term, how are you going to change and do the inner work in order to change your style of relationships? You want to hear something really crazy? Yeah, of course. Yes, please. I don't think I've ever said this anywhere, but I'm going to say it now. So I've had back-to-back relationships, three relationships in a row, with people who were super religious.
我想如果我们没有吸取教训，也没有审视自己的内心，我们往往会一次又一次地吸引同类型的人。这又回到了真正了解和解决爱的概念。这不单单是经常去做水疗，尽管这些事情在当下能让你感觉很好，但从长远来看，你将如何改变并做内心建设，从而改变你的恋爱模式？你想听一件非常疯狂的事吗？当然。是的，请讲。我想我从来没有在任何地方说过这件事，但我现在要说了。我曾经历过接连不断的恋爱，连续三段恋情，对象都是超级宗教狂热的人。
And it caused problems in all of them because the religion was always the divider between us. It was like a common, I felt like it was a karmic lesson of some sort because it was three back-to-back. No one, I've never met anyone who's gotten themselves in a situation like. this before. I don't think I have either list. This is very unique. I feel like it's a very unique story that I'll eventually share in more detail publicly. I think I just held off on it because I'm still trying to figure out the root cause of how that could happen. And I've done a lot of research on karmic relationships and karmic ties and how you keep meeting the same person in a different physical body over and over again until you learn the lesson.
这在所有这些关系中都引发了问题，因为宗教总是我们之间的分水岭。这就像是一个共同的，我觉得某种业力教训，因为那是接连三段。没有人，我从未见过有人自己陷入过这样的情况。我想我也没有，莉丝。这是非常独特的。我觉得这是一个非常独特的故事，以后我会公开分享更多细节。我想我只是把它搁置了，因为我还在试图找出这是如何发生的根本原因。我做了很多关于业力关系、业力羁绊的研究，以及你是如何在不同的肉体中一次又一次地遇到同一个人，直到你吸取了教训。
I think that's a very maybe too spiritual and deep take on this, but I feel like part of my journey in this lifetime is to learn that lesson and work on that part of myself. That's something that I'm working on right now. I just thought it kind of tied into the whole idea of attracting the same person over and over again. It's pretty wild. That is insane that that happened. And honestly, evidence in itself, it's a comic lesson, right? It's the universe trying to direct you on a different path at this point.
我觉得对于这一点，这个看法可能有点过于精神和深刻了，但我觉得我这一生旅程的一部分就是吸取这个教训，并努力完善我自己的那部分。这是我目前正在努力的事情。我只是觉得这和“一次又一次吸引同一个人”的整个概念联系在一起。这太疯狂了。发生这种事真是太疯狂了。老实说，这本身就是证据，这是一个业力教训，对吧？这是宇宙在此时试图引导你走向一条不同的道路。
Are you religious at all? Like, very intensely religious? I am not even, no. I mean, there's nothing wrong with being religious, but I didn't grow up with, I was raised Catholic, but I'm not, I don't define myself as religious. And I'm spiritual. I believe in a higher power, but I don't think too deeply into things. I just trust that the universe is there.
你信教吗？比如，非常笃信宗教？我甚至不信，不。我的意思是，信教没有什么不对，但我不是伴随着宗教长大的，我是在天主教家庭长大的，但我不是，我不认为自己是有宗教信仰的。我是个灵修者。我相信有某种更高的力量，但我不会把事情想得太深。我只是相信宇宙就在那里。
are guiding me. And there's nothing wrong with being religious. I was very drawn into people who were religious, maybe because I was constantly seeking new information, new perspectives, new beliefs. I love meeting people from different backgrounds and different cultures than me. So I think that ties in a lot to my identity. And I've always seen myself marrying someone of a different culture. I don't know why. I'm just drawn to people who, who are different. So I think that ties a lot into these people that I'm attracting. Like, maybe I should, you know, get to the bottom of why I need someone that's impossible to be with. Impossible to be with. Well, that's what I was thinking. I was like, how did you even meet these people?
在指引着我。信教没有什么不对。我非常被信奉宗教的人吸引，也许是因为我一直在寻求新的信息、新的视角、新的信仰。我喜欢结识来自不同背景和不同文化的人。所以我认为这在很大程度上与我的身份息息相关。而且我一直觉得自己会嫁给一个不同文化背景的人。我不知道为什么。我就是被那些与众不同的人所吸引。所以我认为这与我所吸引的这些人有很大关系。也许我应该，你知道的，弄清楚为什么我需要一个不可能在一起的人。不可能在一起。嗯，我当时就是这么想的。我想，你是怎么认识这些人的？
Like, how, like, were you, how did you find them? Like, why was this repeating? Um, because I was like, if you were someone who was like, oh, I'm deeply Christian, I'd be like, okay, that makes sense. But the way that you put that initially being like, I've had these relationships with three people back to back who were super religious, kind of was like insinuated that you weren't. So that's actually such a good explanation. Maybe it's self-sabotage.
比如，你是怎么，你是怎么找到他们的？为什么这种事会重复发生？嗯，因为我想，如果你是一个说“哦，我是一个虔诚的基督徒”的人，我会觉得，好吧，这说得通。但你最初的说法是，你和三个超级宗教的人谈过恋爱，这似乎暗示你不是。所以这其实是一个很好的解释。也许这是自我毁灭。
My therapist said this to me yesterday. Because I do, I, not as like crazy coincidence as you, but I've just like had these relationships back to back where it has started and ended the exact same way. They've all been these like, situationships where like three months in, I realize that this person doesn't want commitment. They've all been with like guys who like I need to mother in some way who are not capable of taking care of themselves like either I'm teaching them how to drive or like they're really
我的治疗师昨天对我这么说。因为我确实，我，虽然没有你那么疯狂的巧合，但我只是有过这样一段接连不断的恋情，开始和结束的方式完全一样。它们都是那种“situationship（暧昧关系）”，大概三个月后，我意识到这个人并不想承诺。这些对象都是那种我需要某种程度上当他们老妈的男生，他们没有照顾自己的能力，要么是我教他们开车，要么他们真的很
lonely in a new city or I'm like teaching them this or that or need financial support and they're all exactly the same. It's like ridiculous. Wow. That's I know it's so sad. That can be draining on a person, too, if you're mothering people in relationships. Oh, yeah. I was like, it was a lot. But I think it's interesting what you said about, like, what's the lesson I need to learn here? And I do believe that the universe will keep sending you the same person until you've learned that lesson. Oh, yeah.
在一个新城市里感到孤独，或者是我在教他们这个或那个，或者需要经济支持，而且他们完全一样。这简直太荒谬了。哇。我知道，这太可悲了。如果在恋爱中当老妈子，这也是很消耗精力的。哦，是的。我当时觉得，这太累了。但我认为你刚才说的很有意思，比如，我在这里需要吸取什么教训？我确实相信，宇宙会不断给你派来同一个人，直到你吸取了这个教训。哦，是的。
I'm a product of that. I'm a case study. I really do believe that we attract certain people in our life based on lessons we need to learn. And that doesn't mean you can't end up together. Whoever if you're dating someone now, it's not always, you know, the lesson is you got to learn this and then you're done. Sometimes it's just about, you know, meeting people to level up and grow. And if you grow with someone and you grow with a partner, that's the best benefit of being in a relationship, in my opinion, is learning more about yourself, learning lessons and growing and evolving as a person.
我是这方面的产物。我是一个个案研究。我真的相信，我们根据需要吸取的教训吸引生命中的特定人群。这并不意味着你们不能走到一起。无论你现在是否在和某人约会，并不总是意味着，你知道的，教训就是你必须学会这个然后就结束了。有时它只是关于结识新的人来升级和成长。如果你和某人一起成长，与伴侣一起成长，在我看来，处于恋爱关系中的最大好处就是更多地了解自己，吸取教训，作为一个人不断成长和进化。
So it's not all bad. You know, I did learn a lot. I did take a lot from these relationships. But yeah, it was the same situation over and over again. And part of me wonders if it was fully in my control because you can't really help who you have a connection with. You can't really help who you fall in love with. I've learned that the hard way.
所以这并不全是坏事。你知道的，我确实学到了很多。我确实从这些感情中收获了很多。但是是的，同样的情况一次又一次地上演。我有时会想，这完全在我的控制之中吗，因为你真的无法控制你和谁有连接。你真的无法控制你会爱上谁。我通过痛苦的方式学到了这一点。
I resisted. The last guy I was with, I found out he was. religious. It's not like I was like, all right, I'm on board. I hesitated so much. And I resisted it for so long because I said to him, I've already been down this road before. This is impossible. This can't work. And he was so persistent. And he was like, I really like you. And I really want to, you know, he was promising me all these things, which he was an amazing person. I have nothing bad to say about him. But the situation was the same. And I knew it. But yet I couldn't help myself. I just. There's something about it. There is something about it. That's really interesting as well.
我抗拒了。我交往的最后一个男生，我发现他是信教的。这并不是说我想，好吧，我加入。我犹豫了很久。我抗拒了很久，因为我对他说，我已经走过这条路了。这是不可能的。这行不通。但他非常坚持。他说，我真的很喜欢你。我真的很想，你知道的，他向我承诺了所有这些事情，他是一个非常棒的人。我对他没有任何不好的评价。但情况还是一样的。我知道。但我还是无法自拔。我只是。这其中有些东西。这其中确实有些东西。这也非常有趣。
Like by the third time round, you were like, oh no, no, no. Like, I've done this before. I've been here before, like a huge instance of like deja vu. How long did you end up dating him for? The last relationship was two and a half years. Wow. And yeah, and the thing is he was the best boyfriend I've ever had. He was an amazing partner. And he taught me so much about self-love because in my past relationships, I had been treated badly. So throughout that whole relationship, I think I took so much value with me because he treated me perfectly. I have nothing bad to say about him as a person.
就像第三次的时候，你会想，哦，不，不，不。就像，我以前做过这个。我以前来过这里，就像一种强烈的Déjà vu（似曾相识）的感觉。你最后和他交往了多久？上一段感情维持了两年半。哇。而且，问题是他是我有过的最好的男友。他是一个出色的伴侣。他教会了我很多关于自爱的事情，因为在过去的感情中，我受过不好的对待。所以在整段感情中，我觉得我带走了很多价值，因为他对待我完美无瑕。作为一个人，我对他没有任何不好的评价。
And it was my worst heartbreak because he was such an amazing boyfriend. And the fact that there was this block in between us, there was obviously a lot more that I'm not discussing right now that happened. it was devastating, but also it taught me so much about who I am and also how I want to be treated because it set the standard really high. So from this point forward, I'm really grateful that I went through that because I know what I want. And it ties into that whole idea of self-worth. Like, I know what I want now and I'm not going to settle for a shitty-ass relationship. Yeah, it's just life is too short.
这是我经历过的最惨痛的心碎，因为他是一个如此出色的男友。而且我们之间存在着这种隔阂，显然还有很多我现在没有讨论过的事情发生了，这令人心碎，但也教会了我很多关于我是谁，以及我希望如何被对待，因为他把标准提得很高。所以从现在开始，我真的很感激我经历了这一切，因为我知道自己想要什么。这与自我价值的整体概念息息相关。比如，我现在知道自己想要什么了，我不会满足于一段糟糕透顶的感情。是的，人生太短暂了。
and I think that sometimes it's actually really ties back into what you were saying around people do you need to be healed to love or can love heal you and I think it is part of that rhetoric right like relationships are going to teach you things about yourself and one of those might be what your worth is how you deserve to be treated and it's not like you need a relationship to teach you that it's not like you can't figure that out for yourself but sometimes it is such a an intense experience to finally be in a situation and be like, wow, this is what it is normal. Like, this is what I should be expecting. Like, you learn so much about yourself. But I do also think, I do think that you learn a lot from heartbreak as well. And I would say that I've learned more about myself in those periods after a relationship or a situation has ended, then what I've learned during the relationship, because it puts my whole life into perspective, I'm kind of like taking count of all my lessons, trying to figure out
而且我认为有时候这实际上真的和你刚才说的话息息相关，关于人们是需要治愈才能去爱，还是爱可以治愈你，我认为这是那种言论的一部分，对吧？就像恋爱会教给你关于你自己的事情，其中之一可能就是你的价值是什么，你值得怎样的对待。这并不是说你需要一段感情来教你这一点，并不是说你自己弄不明白，但有时这是一次如此深刻的体验，最终处于某种情境中，然后想，哇，原来正常是这样的。就像，这正是我应该期待的。你会对自己了解很多。但我确实也认为，从心碎中你也会学到很多。而且我会说，在一段感情或关系结束之后的那些时期，我对自己的了解比在恋爱期间还要多，因为它让我的人生观变得清晰，我有点像是在清点我所有的教训，试图弄清楚
where I stand, why it didn't work, and what I want next? Like, would you say that, obviously, I'm assuming this was the guy behind the reason you started this podcast, right? Yes. Oh, wow, look at that. Yeah. So obviously. It was. And it, obviously, there were, a lot of things I took with a breakup, including being productive, starting a new project. And I talk about this on my podcast as well about turning pain into creativity. Because if you're going to take something positive out of a breakup, it has to be something that makes you feel good, right? So why not start a new project? Why not start a new passion project that you've been thinking about and holding off on because you were consumed by this relationship?
我的立场是什么，为什么它不管用，以及我接下来想要什么？你会这么说吗，显然，我猜这就是你开始这个播客的那个男人，对吧？是的。哦，哇，你看。是的。所以很明显。确实是。而且，显然，我在分手中学到了很多东西，包括变得富有成效、开启一个新项目。我在我的播客中也谈到了这一点，关于将痛苦转化为创造力。如果你要从分手中学到积极的东西，那一定是一件能让你感觉良好的事情，对吧？所以为什么不开启一个新项目呢？为什么不开启一个你一直在考虑、却因为被这段感情消耗而搁置的新的热爱项目呢？
Relationships take up a lot of time. I mean, from my experiences, if you have someone constantly coming in and out of your life, it can be very time consuming. So putting your new, I mean, I guess when you have more time on your hands after a breakup, you have more time to get creative and you have more time to. work on new things so i started the podcast it was a blessing and disguise i say yeah i agree and i do think it's like sometimes rejection i love this phrase i know it's like a super common one but like rejection is just redirection and as i've gotten older i realized how much that is the case like every relationship that didn't work out has sent me to a new place in terms of my personal growth or like you know that my last three people that I dated, it was like one of them, I started this podcast. The next one,
恋爱占据了大量时间。我的意思是，根据我的经验，如果有人不断地进出你的生活，那会非常耗费时间。所以把你的新……我的意思是，我想当你在分手后有更多空闲时间时，你有更多时间发挥创造力，也有更多时间去着手新事物。所以我开了这个播客，因祸得福吧，我是这么说的。是的，我同意。而且我确实认为有时拒绝——我喜欢这个短语，我知道这超级常见，但拒绝就是重定向。随着年龄的增长，我意识到这种情况有多普遍——每一段没有成功的感情都把我送到了一个新的地方，无论是在个人成长方面，还是像，你知道的，我最近交往的三个对象，其中一个，我开启了这个播客。下一个，
I moved to Sydney because I was like, I can't be in the same city as you. So, um, and then like, so where were you living? I was living in Canberra. Most, do you know what that is? It's like, yeah, so I, I studied abroad in Australia for a year. Oh, really? Wait, in Canberra? No. No, no. Um, I was in Bundora. Andorra? I don't even... Do you know where that is? I live here and I don't even know what that is. I'm dead.
我搬到了悉尼，因为我觉得我不能和你呆在同一个城市。所以，嗯，然后就像，那你之前住在哪里？我住在堪培拉。大多数，你知道那是什么吗？就是，是的，所以我曾在澳大利亚留学了一年。哦，真的吗？等等，在堪培拉？不。不，不。嗯，我在邦多拉（Bundoora）。安道尔？我甚至……你知道那在哪里吗？我住在这里，我甚至不知道那是什么。我笑死。
Where is it? Okay, so this is so embarrassing, and I don't want to go off to off topic, but I didn't do any research before I went to Australia. Like a fool. I don't know why I didn't ask someone for help. And I booked this university called La Trobe, which is in the middle of absolutely nowhere. It's literally in the middle of nowhere. It's on a farm in Bandora. That's where it's an hour outside of Melbourne.
它在哪儿？好吧，这太尴尬了，我不想跑题，但在去澳大利亚之前我没有做任何研究。就像个傻子一样。我不知道为什么我没有向别人寻求帮助。我报读了这所名叫拉筹伯（La Trobe）的大学，它位于绝对荒郊野岭。字面意思上的荒郊野岭。它在邦多拉的一个农场里。那是墨尔本郊外一个小时车程的地方。
So I thought I was going to Melbourne and I got there and I was on a farm and I made a huge mistake. Oh, frick. That's not good. I went to Sydney. Did you have fun? I went to Sydney for two weeks. I explored Sydney for a bit. I did all the major cities and places.
所以我以为我要去墨尔本，结果到了那里，我发现自己在农场里，我犯了一个大错。哦，操。那可不太妙。我去了悉尼。你玩得开心吗？我在悉尼呆了两个星期。我在悉尼探索了一会儿。我去过所有主要的城市和地方。
I didn't miss out too much. So, yeah. Yeah, except for like all those weeks when you were in the... middle of nowhere. Yeah, I was definitely sad that I made a huge mistake, but I would travel a lot and I, yeah, I was, I was all over the place, so it wasn't too bad, but huge mistake. Lesson learned to do your research before you go to a new country. Yeah, don't go to Bandura. Like, when the locals don't even know where that is, then you know that you're in trouble. That's really funny. I also grew up in Melbourne, so I should know, but that's crazy.
我没有错过太多。所以，是的。是的，除了你在那个荒郊野岭的那些星期。是的，我确实为自己犯了弥天大错而感到难过，但我经常旅行，而且，是的，我到处跑，所以还算过得去，但真是个弥天大错。吸取教训，去新国家之前一定要做好研究。是的，别去邦多拉。当当地人都不知道那在哪儿时，你就知道自己遇到麻烦了。这太搞笑了。我也在墨尔本长大，所以我应该知道的，但这太疯狂了。
I don't know how we enjoy... Oh, yeah. Yeah, so I used to live in Canberra. I like, did uni there. And I met this guy and, oh my God. Like, my first impression of him was like, this guy is totally, you're totally out of his league. Like, absolutely totally out of this guy's league. and then he kind of just like wore me down
我不知道我们怎么享受……哦，是的。是的，所以我以前住在堪培拉。我在那里上大学。我遇到了这个家伙，天哪。我对他的第一印象是，这这家伙完全，你完全配不上他。绝对完全配不上这家伙。
one minute I was like I could never one minute I was like like stop messaging me getting the ink and the next minute I was like and the next minute I was like madly in love with him and I was like where did how did this happen like this happened like overnight it was also during COVID lockdown so you know
前一分钟我还觉得我绝对不行，前一分钟我还觉得就像别再发信息了，滚蛋吧，下一分钟我又觉得，下一分钟我发现自己疯狂地爱上了他，然后我想，这是怎么发生的？这怎么发生的？就像一夜之间一样。当时也正处于新冠封锁期间，所以你知道的
everything's a bit more heightened I always call it like COVID goggles oh yeah it was oh my god it was totally a COVID goggles I was like, oh my God, because in Australia, like, you could go and see like an intimate partner. So I was like, ah, this means I can leave my house. Like, yes. Yeah, but like, sorry, off track, but that relationship is what really pushed me to move to Sydney.
一切都有点被放大了，我总是称之为“新冠滤镜”。哦，对，真的，完全就是新冠滤镜。我当时想：“哦天哪，因为在澳大利亚，你可以去见一个亲密伴侣。”所以我当时想：“啊，这意味着我可以离开家了，太棒了。”是的，但是抱歉，扯远了，不过那段感情确实促使我搬到了悉尼。
And I think if I had still been with him when I was moving, I probably would have moved back to Canberra. Because I, there was just such a pool there. Like, it was what I knew. But because that relationship, um, um, But because that relationship had ended, I was like, well, I guess I got to stick it out. And then the last one was just someone who taught me so much around, I guess, like we said, self-worth. And it was like the first person who I was like, wow, you actually treated me really well. And I really liked you, but this was actually not going to work.
我想如果我搬家的时候还跟他在一起，我可能会搬回堪培拉。因为那里对我有很大的吸引力，那是我熟悉的环境。但因为那段感情结束了，我想，好吧，我得咬牙坚持下去。最后一段感情让我学到了很多关于自我价值的东西。他是第一个让我觉得“哇，你对我真的很好，我也很喜欢你，但这其实是行不通的”的人。
And it's because that I actually need something more from this relationship. rather than you just being kind to me. And it was one that I realized that, like, that's the baseline. Like, that is the bare minimum is to be a nice guy. I don't need to fall in love with someone just because they treat me with respect. Oh, yeah. That's a, you're so wise. It was your birthday, like, today, right?
这是因为我在这段感情中确实需要更多的东西，而不仅仅是你对我和善。我意识到这只是底线，做个好人是最低标准。我不需要仅仅因为某人以礼相待就爱上他。哦，对，你太成熟了。今天是你的生日，对吧？
Yesterday? Oh, like two days ago, yeah. Well, happy birthday. Another year around the sun. Thanks. Yeah, like, how old did you turn 23? Yeah, at 23. So I'm still a baby.
昨天？哦，大概两天前吧。嗯，生日快乐！又长大了一岁。谢谢。对，你今年23岁？对，23岁，所以我还是个宝宝。
No, you're so wise. Like, you definitely had so many past, I believe in past lives. Maybe this is a little bit strange, but I think you had so many past lives because you're just, no, you're so. At 23, I was still going through a lot of different experiences and I had no knowledge of what self-love really was. So I'm blown away by your content and like everything you speak on. so smart and mature like it's crazy i'm i'm 30 so i like i've been through you know that from 23 to 30 i've changed so so much and i've grown so much um but it's so amazing that you're so young and you've like you have so much wisdom under under your belt already thanks what would well maybe we can use
不，你非常成熟。你肯定经历过很多前世，我相信前世。也许这有点奇怪，但我认为你有过很多前世，因为你实在是……不，你太成熟了。我23岁的时候还在经历很多不同的事情，对什么是真正的自爱一无所知。所以我对你的内容和你说的一切都惊叹不已。你太聪明成熟了，简直太疯狂了。我都30岁了，从23岁到30岁，我变了太多，成长了太多。但你这么年轻，就已经拥有如此丰富的智慧，这太神奇了。谢谢。也许我们可以把这个
this as like older sister vibes like what advice would you give me now that i'm i'm i'm 20 I'm still battling through a lot of like shitty dating experiences and bad boyfriends and rejection and hookups that like you want to be more, but they never eventuate. So what's your like major lesson that you could share with us? I think a lot of it comes down to just knowing who you are and knowing what you stand for outside of anyone else, whether it's a friendship or a relationship or your parents, or anyone, just taking alone time to know who you are is so crucial. As I've gotten older, I've realized that when I mesh energies with people and I'm surrounding myself with friends and
当作姐姐和妹妹的对话。既然我已经20多岁了，还在艰难地经历各种糟糕的约会、糟糕的男朋友、拒绝以及那些你希望有结果却总是不了了之的走肾关系，你有什么建议可以给我？你觉得我们可以分享的主要教训是什么？我觉得很大一部分归结于：在任何人——无论是友情、恋爱还是父母——之外，了解你自己是谁，知道你坚守什么。花点独处时间去了解自己是至关重要的。随着年龄的增长，我意识到当我把自己的能量和别人融合，整天和朋友、
family and relationships all the time, I used to lose myself so easily. I used to give my energy away and my value away so easily to people who didn't deserve it. And I always tell people, if you're feeling a little bit lost or you're not sure if someone's right for you or you're anxious and you're questioning everything, take time alone to really get your thoughts in order and actually know what you stand for, what your values are, what you believe in, what your boundaries are, what's important to you. These are things in my early 20s I didn't understand. I never had anyone guiding me. And I would just dive headfirst into relationships with guys that literally didn't give a shit about me.
家人以及伴侣在一起时，我太容易失去自我了。我总是轻易把自己的能量和价值给那些不配的人。我总是告诉别人，如果你觉得有点迷茫，或者不确定某人是否适合你，或者你感到焦虑并在质疑一切，那就花点独处时间好好理清思绪，真正了解你坚守什么、你的价值观是什么、你信仰什么、你的底线是什么、什么对你最重要。这些都是我在20多岁时不懂的事情。我从来没有导师，我会一头扎进那些根本不在乎我的男人的感情里。
And I would spend all my time focusing on that instead of focusing on myself. So I think that's my best advice. I hope that answered that question. I just rambled. But just taking time for you and really knowing who you are as a person, knowing your identity is going to save you a lot of time and a lot of heartbreak. because now at 30, I won't tolerate anything less than what I deserve, and I know what I deserve now.
我会把所有时间都花在关注他们上，而不是关注自己。所以我想这就是我最好的建议。希望这回答了那个问题，我刚才扯远了。但只要花时间陪伴自己，真正了解自己是谁，知道自己的身份，就能为你省去很多时间和心碎。因为现在30岁的我，绝不会容忍任何低于我应得的东西，我现在知道我配得上什么。
And I also will say, don't be too hard on yourself because you kind of need to go through shitty experiences in order to evolve and learn the lessons. I would agree. I would say very few of us end up with the first person that we date. Oh, yeah. We all have these experiences that, will, I think, are valuable because they shape who we are.
我还要说，不要对太自己苛刻，因为你必须经历糟糕的经历才能进化并吸取教训。我非常赞同。我们当中很少有人能和初恋走到最后。哦，是的。我们都有这些经历，我认为它们很有价值，因为它们塑造了我们。
And I don't know about you, but like I look back on a lot of them and I'm like, I'm so grateful that happened. Not all of it. But like, do you have that experience when you look back and you're like, that was awful at the time? But I'm so grateful that I went through that. I do. I think I'm grateful for everything that I've been through, even though there was a moment in time where I thought my world was ending.
我不知道你是不是这样，但当我回首往事时，我会觉得：“我很感激这一切的发生。”虽然不是全部。但你回首过去时，也会觉得当时虽然糟透了，但很庆幸自己经历了这一切吗？我是这样的。我觉得我很感激自己经历过的一切，尽管曾有一段时间我以为世界都要毁灭了。
it was the worst heartbreak that I've been through two years ago with that guy I'd mentioned. And I would always ask myself the question of why am I going through this? Why am I feeling this type of pain? Why do I deserve this? Because I'm a good person and I love someone and I'm being, you know, thrown into this pit of pain. And now, obviously it takes time to sometimes get to a point where you feel okay. Now I look back and I've grown so much and I'm so, so grateful for everything that I've been through and I wouldn't change a thing.
那是两年前经历的最糟糕的心碎，就是我刚才提到那个家伙。我总是问自己：我为什么要经历这些？我为什么要感受这种痛苦？我为什么要承受这些？因为我是个好人，我爱一个人，却被扔进了痛苦的深渊。现在，虽然有时候需要时间才能感觉好点，但当我回首过去时，发现自己成长了这么多，我真的非常非常感激自己经历过的一切，而且我什么都不会改变。
Even though I went through the worst pain of my life, I definitely would not change a thing. So I think, yeah, everything teaches you something and that's a really healthy perspective to have too. You know, it's a healthy perspective that's going to get you through life because shit happens all the time. So. Yeah. Just about how you deal with it. Yeah, rejection is just redirection, I guess. And also I do really love, like, the value of solitude sometimes.
尽管我经历了生命中最痛苦的时刻，但我绝对不会改变任何事情。所以我想，是的，一切都会教给你一些东西，这也是一种非常健康的视角。你知道，这种健康的视角能帮你度过生活中的难关，因为烂事总是不断发生。所以，这完全取决于你如何处理它。是的，拒绝其实就是重定向，我想是这样的。而且我也真的很喜欢有时候独处的力量。
You learn a lot about yourself when you hold up a pretty deep mirror into your soul. And when you aren't distracted by temporary relationships or, like, I don't know if you have this experience, but I often find that whenever I'm having, like, negative emotions, my first, like, my first, like, my first, reaction is to just like fill up my calendar to like have dates lined up to like have dinner plans to be calling people all the time because like that level of like extraversion and social interaction is such an amazing distraction can be like oh I get to focus on these people but something that I've learned like the older I've gotten not that I'm particularly old at this stage but like the more years I've spent on earth um
当你把一面清澈的镜子照向灵魂深处时，你会对自己有很深的了解。当你没有被暂时的关系分心时——或者我不知道你有没有这种经历，但我经常发现，每当我产生负面情绪时，我的第一反应就是把日程塞满，安排好约会，定好晚饭计划，不停地给别人打电话，因为这种外向和社交互动是非常惊人的分心方式，会让我觉得“哦，我可以把注意力集中在这些人身上”。但随着年龄的增长，我学到的一点是——虽然我现在也不是特别老，但在地球上度过的岁月越多，
is that taking like a time like once twice a year to just like separate yourself go away for like four days just do something that is entirely within like entirely like entirely like a solitary activity even if it's just like more regular like turning your phone off sitting at like your table and just like painting like that creative expression we talked about you just see so much growth in yourself so quickly because it's at that point that you don't have to be thinking about what other people think about you. You don't need to be thinking about the impressions of other people. You don't need to be thinking about what they expect or what's next. You can just sit with your emotions and be like, this is actually how I feel about a situation.
就是每年花一两次时间把自己隔离起来，离开四天，做一些完全是独处的事情。哪怕只是更常规的事情——比如关掉手机，坐在桌前画画，就像我们讨论过的那种创意表达，你会看到自己在极短的时间内飞速成长，因为在那个时刻，你不需要去想别人怎么看你。你不需要去考虑别人的印象。你不需要去想他们的期待或下一步是什么。你只需与自己的情绪相处，然后说：“这其实是我对某种情况的真实感受。”
This is how I feel about my feelings. And you can move forward with clarity. I don't know if you agree with that or if you want to add to that. Yeah. I mean, it's so easy to get lost in other people's opinions of what you're going through. if you're constantly asking people for help. And it's okay to ask for help, of course. We all need help at certain points of our life.
这就是我对自己的感受，你可以带着清晰的思路继续前程。我不知道你是否同意这一点，或者你想补充什么。是的，我的意思是，如果你总是向别人寻求帮助，你太容易迷失在别人对你所经历事情的看法中了。当然，寻求帮助是没有问题的。我们在生命的某些阶段都需要帮助。
I just think sometimes you have to listen to your inner voice, and that's the voice that's going to guide you the most. And I've definitely had, you know, friends give me advice, and family give me advice. And I take it with a grain of salt, but you're not really going to listen to anyone unless it's something that you really want to do. And that's something that's really, like if you're not,
我只是觉得有时你必须倾听内心的声音，那是对你最有指导意义的声音。我当然也听过朋友和家人的建议，我对此持保留态度，但除非那是你真正想做的事，否则你不会真正听取任何人的意见。如果你还没准备好，
ready to heal, you're not ready to heal. You're not going to be healed by someone saying, okay, you know, get out of bed and start your day. That's not going to help. The only person that you could really depend on in times of, I guess, hardship is yourself. So that's why I always emphasize the importance of really knowing who you are and taking that alone time. And I totally agree with that. I think, you know, just having that time to yourself is crucial in order to really know how to love yourself but that doesn't mean you can't also be social and also hang out with people and see people it doesn't mean you know crawl in your bed and never leave but i think it's just important to separate your energy from everyone else's every now and then just to recharge and re-center yeah that
准备好疗愈，你就还没准备好疗愈。别人对你说“好了，起床开始新的一天吧”，是无法让你痊愈的。那帮不了你。在艰难困苦时，你真正能依靠的只有自己。这就是为什么我总是强调真正了解自己并留出独处时间的重要性。我完全同意这一点。我认为，拥有属于自己的时间对于真正懂得如何爱自己至关重要，但这并不意味着你不能社交、不能和别人出去玩、不能见人，这并不意味着你要钻进被窝再也不出来。但我认为，时不时地把自己的能量与别人的能量隔离开来，以便重新充电和重塑中心，真的很重要。是的，
i think that's an amazing point and an awesome way and kind of an awesome point to finish on it's been such a lovely discussion you know we've talked about like to summarize it all. We've really worked through so many different things that I think come up on our self-love journey, but also on our dating journey as well. Self-worth, dealing with rejection, alone time, the creativity and opportunities that come from heartbreak. So, Liz, thank you so much for coming on and sharing all your wisdom. Thank you so much for having me. I loved that conversation. And I hope that helped all of you. of you and I hope that was a you know productive conversation I feel like we could talk for so long
我觉得这是一个极好的观点，也是一个完美的收尾。这是一次非常愉快的讨论，我们讨论了——总结一下——我们确实探讨了许多在追求自爱以及约会旅程中会出现的不同问题。自我价值、应对拒绝、独处时间、创造力以及心碎带来的机遇。所以，莉斯，非常感谢你来参加节目并分享你的智慧。非常感谢邀请我。我很喜欢这次谈话，希望这能对大家有所帮助，希望这是一次富有成效的谈话。我觉得我们能聊好久呢，
I lost track of time yeah I did as well I'm thinking part two has to happen because these are the conversations I love having honestly because I often feel like these are the conversations that a lot of people like I want to have these with my friends but sometimes like that doesn't happen so I'm like come and come and listen to us dissect our love lives for your entertainment I love doing that And also, I'm just going to give you a podcast a shout out. Date yourself instead. If you're not listening to it, it's amazing. It's super valuable content, especially if you're someone who's going through a hard time in terms of your romantic life.
我都忘了时间了。是的，我也是。我在想一定要有第二期节目，因为这些正是我喜欢进行的对话。说实话，我经常觉得这些对话很多人都想和朋友聊，但有时这并不会发生，所以我想说：来吧，来听我们剖析自己的爱情生活来娱乐你们吧。我很喜欢这样做。另外，我要顺便推荐一个播客《Date Yourself Instead》（不如和自己约会）。如果你没听过，它真的很棒。里面的内容超级有价值，特别是如果你正处于感情生活的艰难时期。
I couldn't recommend it more highly. If you're listening, you really enjoyed this episode. I know that we both did a lot. Maybe you want to share it with a friend. If it's something that a friend needs to hear, please. feel free to pass on the love. If you did enjoy this episode, please leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. It really helps the show to grow and reach new people. And if you want to know more, if you want to be ahead of the news, ahead of the
我强烈推荐。如果你正在听，并且真的很享受这一期节目——我知道我们俩都很享受——也许你想把它分享给朋友。如果这是某个朋友需要听到的内容，请随心所欲地传递这份爱。如果你确实喜欢这一期节目，请在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听的任何平台上留下五星好评。这真的对节目的成长和触达新听众大有帮助。如果你想了解更多，想走在新闻和节目更新的前面，
episodes, follow me at That Psychology Podcast. I post a lot of updates around what's coming next, merchandise, guests that are coming on. And also once a month, I let you the listeners choose what episode comes out next. So thank you so much and have a lovely week. We'll be back soon with another episode. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Care Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere,
请关注我@That Psychology Podcast。我发布了很多关于接下来会发生什么、周边商品以及即将登场嘉宾的更新。另外，每个月我都会让听众来决定下一期播客的内容。非常感谢大家，祝你们度过愉快的一周。我们很快会推出下一期节目。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Care Games）主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个节目关注黑人男性的经历，进行在其他地方真的不太安全进行的坦诚对话，
but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct?
但你是在和一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人身披盔甲？这向世界传递了一个信号：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeart广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。艾伦女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吧？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批网络侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式：另外两个经历过相同事情的男人——格雷格·吉利斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs. when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness,
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%.
我剖析了在我们这个奇异的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是TWO%。
On the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱的。他会得到应有的惩罚。
We always say that, trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。谢谢。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何一句话即可发表评论。